All right.
Uh,
let's,
uh,
proceed with our discussion of musical style and this is going to be mostly a
comparison of musical style in different style periods.
And we put the titles of those style periods up on the board there.
Once again,
this is a typically western exercise that we are dealing with here.
We love to organize materials so that we can simplify it and we can deal with it
whether it's attributing to a single individual,
what uh,
a large number of people do,
whether it's grouping random units of pulses into meter or whether it's taking a
highly complex group of phenomenon and putting them in a particular style
periods.
We like to do that because it allows us to,
to deal with the material in some kind of organized fashion.
So we've got our various periods up here as mentioned that we won't be going
into,
uh,
to the postmodernist in any significant way here.
Now,
what you'll be asked to do is identify the period in which a particular piece is
written and if it turns out that on our final test we happened to play for you,
a piece that's on the list of pieces that we give you,
then you're responsible for identifying the name of the composer and the name of
the piece.
If it's not,
if the piece we play is not on your list,
then all you would be asked to do is identify the style period.
However you're asked to do something even more important than that,
and that's to tell us why it's in this particular style period.
It does.
No good.
I don't think,
just as a romantic and then we're going to walk away from it.
What I would ask you to do is give us three or four,
uh,
specific points that you hear in the music that corroborate your decision with
regard to the style period.
Now you may wish to take a look at your textbook there around page 67 68 69
where there's an introduction to a musical style and the checklist as I call it,
a checklist of musical style by period.
And that'll kind of get you thinking in these in these sorts of ways.
The Baroque music for example,
tends to have rather long asymmetrical themes but very driving sorts of rhythm.
So you could,
uh,
learn that checklist for each of these periods.
But the important thing is that when we play the music,
you have got to hear in that music,
that particular,
um,
uh,
phenomenon or characteristic that you list on your,
a group of three or four,
um,
uh,
factors that lead you to your conclusion.
For example,
you may recognize that piece of B as being of the romantic period and say that
it has lots of low brass in it and it may not have any low brass in the music
we're playing at all.
So,
uh,
that we will,
that wouldn't be doing much for us there.
So we want to hear the music and we want to take things out of the music that
we're actually hearing.
So maybe we'll start with a piece here.
Now what we've got is a series of of six,
seven depends on how many you want this morning.
Uh,
a particular piece has chosen to exemplify these various style periods.
So I think let's go right to my track.
Uh,
let's see,
let's go to s CD two there and I want track 10 if I may please Linda.
And then Linda later on is going to talk about some of this too.
She's got a surprise piece for us.
Um,
so let's start with track.
Uh,
10 and let's go to a,
at four minutes and 30 seconds there of track 10.
Now what are you going to be listening for here?
I was thinking about that this morning.
What's the most important thing when trying to identify style?
What will allow you to get to the answer quickest?
What do you think it is?
What are you going to be listening for?
Okay,
let's go back to the radio in the car business or you suddenly turn on some sort
of streaming FM middle of a piece.
What is it that's going to give you the most information?
Roger Instruments,
right?
Absolutely.
Okay.
It's the instruments because if you hear lots of percussion and xylophones and,
uh,
things such as that banging away in a dissonant fashion,
those instruments just weren't there.
And the time,
time of Mozart for example.
So,
you know,
it's gotta be a probably late 19th century and on.
So dis instruments is the single most important factor.
Uh,
but some instruments are common to many,
many different periods of the piano operated roughly from when to when,
if you hear a piano,
what does that tell you about the time period of the music that your classical
music that you're listening to?
It's gotta be roughly after what?
After or after who,
when did the piano,
uh,
really become the principal keyboard instrument in Western culture?
Roughly 1770 or so.
1760 1770.
As I've said,
Mozart was the first two.
If you really use the piano exclusively.
So,
uh,
if you hear a piano,
it,
it can't be renaissance or medieval,
it can't be borough,
it could be classical romantic,
impressionist,
modern.
And then on the basis of other things,
you would come to a conclusion about this,
the style periods,
what might something else be?
Roger,
uh,
with the help of Caroline there was able to tell us that instrumentation was
very important here after instrumentation.
Uh,
what is it that we might be listening for?
I'm Marcus.
Okay.
Yeah.
The volume of the size of it.
That in some way.
Yeah.
So this specifically speaking,
it's not just instruments,
it could be volume as well.
And the leader,
what,
what's the pinnacle in terms of volume?
What would you say?
Is it,
is it all just a straight line,
a scent and to present day in terms of volume wins?
The biggest orchestra around,
we talked about that.
Marcus.
Okay.
Romantic.
Can you refine it any further than that?
Late Romantic Mahler,
Strauss,
that kind of thing.
Mahler.
Roto symphony of a thousand.
He called,
he had a thousand performer in it.
So it's late 19th,
early 20th century.
Uh,
and then it,
there's sort of an odd way kind of declines thereafter.
So volume is important.
Um,
just to move things along here.
I think the harmony is important to,
uh,
and you can pick out sometimes chords,
not necessarily the specific courts,
but does it kind of,
so plain vanilla,
vanilla a harmony or does it sound a little bit surprising or shocking?
Not Shocking,
but bracing unexpected.
Well,
the more unexpected it becomes probably the leader you are,
the more into the romantic period you are.
And most importantly,
I think maybe even more important than that is the element of consonance versus
dissonance when we begin to get a heavy component of dissonance in high art
music in the west
classical period,
romantic period,
impressionist period.
A little bit.
Yeah,
I see Kristen
maybe.
Okay.
Yeah.
So a little bit in the impressionist period and then heavy in the modernist
period and then it kind of actually a backs down in the postmodern period,
but we're not going to get Roger.
Good point.
It can be present in medieval music.
So in an odd way,
yeah.
Uh,
the,
the notion of continent harmonies really didn't get formed until the 15th
century.
So if you're listening to things before the 15th century,
sometimes you can find rather bracing,
inviting dissonance in medieval music and then it sort of smoothed itself out
for 500 years.
Um,
okay,
so I think we have our first selection queue now.
So let's just listen to this and these are going to be rather long as they will
be in the test.
Pause it here now.
Just pause it.
Okay.
So we've heard that lunch right off the bat.
Something should be ruled out.
So what do we want to rule out here?
Douglas in the back?
Picking over cold call people today.
Yes,
Doug.
Uh,
what would we rule?
What would we rule out there?
Okay.
Classical Mozart,
Haydn,
even Beethoven,
we would rule out classical and we're ruling out classical it.
That sort of wipes out what basically everything else before.
So it can't be anything after,
uh,
excuse me,
before,
uh,
well,
can't be any,
anything really before 1800.
So we'll start with romantic.
So still in the game here,
romantic,
impressionist and modernist.
Any thoughts about that?
Romantic,
impressionist,
modern Caroline?
I don't.
You just tell me,
don't tell me the,
what you think the answer is.
Just tell me what you heard there.
Louder please.
Okay.
So maybe possibly some strange sounding scales and some bells you said.
W what did you hear?
Uh,
what else did you win?
Big Orchestra,
little orchestra,
a big garden,
huge orchestra.
Huge Orchestra and huge sound.
Okay.
So where does that put us in the,
the spectrum here?
Uh,
1800 to 2000.
Okay,
well we talked about that probably around around 1900 or so with an orchestra
that big a and you heard voices in it,
which is interesting to comment on all shots.
So then you might have chuffed.
Well,
is this Beethoven?
Oh,
it's too big for Beethoven.
It's too,
there's too much of,
is too rich for Beethoven.
Is it Wagner?
It's probably even too rich for Wagner.
It's just a bigger,
um,
so we're pushing on here,
uh,
after 1850.
Let's listen to a bit more and because the excerpts that we will have on next
Wednesday,
we'll be longer.
Let's listen to a bit more and see if we can gather some more information here.
Okay.
Just stop right there.
What are we hearing?
They're very important piece of information.
Yeah.
What was that?
What instrument was playing?
Oboe was playing Daniel.
Okay.
They had the melody.
And what about that melody?
How did it go?
What's that?
Yes.
Kristen's got it out there.
Nice and loud please.
It's an Austin auto.
So what does that tell us if we're trying,
which one of the three of these style periods does that knock out of the box?
Romantic,
impressionist or modern?
We talked about that in a lecture on impressionism,
but by the same token,
you were listening exercise 42 on Stravinsky foregrounded precisely this
phenomenon of Austin auto.
So there we have romantic being taken out of the mix here.
This idea of Stacy's is not part of the aesthetic of Romanticism.
Romantic.
If flows even grows,
it expands it contracts.
Uh,
but it doesn't constantly reiterate one phenomenon.
So we were down to impressionist or modern here.
Let's go on,
listen to just a little bit more.
Okay.
Uh,
stop it there.
So what did we hear there?
Anything more that we could add to our list of identifiers?
Um,
Oscar,
good parallel motion,
Yardi,
Dee Dee,
those word wins.
We're going up and down in the same direction.
Parallel motion.
Excellent.
It,
there's one other thing here at the very end we heard what played by a harp.
Yeah.
Caroline,
a Glissando that kind of walk.
So based on that,
obviously we are dealing with a piece of impressionist music.
This is Ravel's Daphnis and Chloe ballet music for one of those Diaghilev
ballets that we were talking about,
uh,
in section last time.
So what would we say here?
Well,
we would say large colorful orchestra.
Actually,
there was also the use of the human voice here,
which we heard in WC as well.
We would say also that it's essentially a consonant and not a dissident,
essentially a consonant environment.
We would say that we have a parallel motion as Oscar pointed out,
we would say that we have,
um,
possibly if you wanted to throw this in a scales that are not true,
traditional,
although that's a little bit hard to hear,
but certainly we had the Glissando.
So if you're looking for,
for sound bites here,
or four bullet points to put on your paper,
large,
colorful orchestra concert,
that backdrop parallelism and what did we say?
The glissando at the very end and you're finished,
you're out,
you get 100%.
Okay.
So that's piece number one.
And that's sort of the thought process that I hope you would use while working
through this particular exercise.
Let's go on to a piece number two,
um,
which I think,
yeah,
let's do my track.
I just track one.
Let's see what we got there.
Hope or no,
no,
let's go to on that particular wireless play track one and see what happens.
Okay.
Play track.
Uh,
I believe it's track five and we'll get holish
right sheet.
Phooey.
Uh,
excuse me.
Yeah,
it's on my list here.
track five.
Track five.
What about this one?
Oh,
did we switch on to the next CD?
Okay.
We're going to go to the next CD now.
Uh,
for another,
another piece.
Sorry,
my fault.
Oh,
uh,
let's go to track one of [inaudible] play track by,
what was that?
Please try it with play by what you just played.
Oh,
okay.
Let's stop there.
What's a good example of what Chin Gregorian chant La
Chad and kept it there.
Let's go on to track one.
[inaudible]
okay.
That's really beautiful.
It's weird that this beautiful setting of,
well you tell me what period it comes from.
Okay.
I'm going to move skipper,
skip around a little bit.
Let me go to,
um,
Emily please.
Behind a medieval and renaissance,
we had chant there and on the same CD we have an example of,
this is actually sort of right between the two,
which are written by Thomas Tallis in England,
but England was sort of slow to catch up to the renaissance.
So it's,
it's,
it's late medieval,
early,
early renaissance.
What specifically did we hear here that leads you to,
that can collusion?
Um,
judge.
Jennifer.
Jessica?
Nope.
Sorry,
what?
Angela?
Sorry.
Okay.
We heard multiple unaccompanied voices.
Uh,
what kind of texture was being employed there?
Huh?
Mostly polyphonic and we said we were dealing with textures.
We had imitative and non imitative polyphonic textures.
Was this imitative or non imitative?
Everybody agree with that?
Anyone disagree with it?
Some people are shaking their head it was non imitative.
Oh no,
excuse me.
It was imitative.
If I had time to play it again,
you could hear one voice would come in GP.
No Man.
Tachy oh and then somebody else would come in.
He GP low man totty and then the third voice in the fourth voyage.
But you're right to say multiple voices unaccompanied.
So you,
you sort of get two points for that.
Uh,
and um,
uh,
what do we call that?
A unaccompanied style.
Yeah.
So,
but when you don't get a separate point for Acappella on the company,
acapella style would be one,
one marker there at the idea imitative voices would be another.
Uh,
you might even pick up on the text,
I suppose that it's in,
in what language?
Latin.
Yeah.
What else there that it's not particularly rhythmic.
No strong rhythms or meters.
It sort of flows gently like a good Gorean Chan.
And as mentioned,
we have this texture that's uh,
uh,
not only polyphonic but highly imitative.
And those are all hallmarks of late medieval and renaissance music.
That particular piece was written by English composer Thomas Tallis,
but more interesting in a way,
it's a setting of the old limitations of Jeremiah out of the old testament that
laments the fall of Jerusalem.
So it's a particularly dark,
heartfelt Texas exquisitely sat there in that renaissance vocal style.
Uh,
let's go on to another one now.
The next cds,
probably CD three and four.
This,
we do have track five,
I believe.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
sometimes you can figure this out in about three seconds.
It doesn't take much more than,
so with just that,
and we'll be playing a lot more than three seconds,
many minutes.
And depending upon the particular piece,
probably more than once.
So,
um,
what did you hear there?
And we may go back and hear just that much.
What did you hear there?
Let's talk about what you heard and then we'll conclude about the period in
question.
So someone get a starter.
Uh,
Nicole.
Okay.
A lot of percussion.
The uh,
very,
uh,
definitely particularly the tip and Marcos,
lot of dissonance that was very prominent.
It started out okay.
It could have been a kind of John Williams star wars type sound up into the,
about the third iteration of one particular figure,
but the level of the pitches at which it was brought in,
produced a very dissonant moment there.
So,
well maybe John Williams and romanticism knock off kind of thing.
But uh,
when that dissonance in the dissident enters,
then that takes you into a slightly different realm.
Uh,
Daniel.
Okay.
A lot of brass and even if they were not percussion instruments,
those instruments were being used in a kind of percussive in your face way.
Yeah.
So those are three good things.
Roger,
you've got another one.
I beg your pardon?
Yes,
there were lots of Ostinato right at the beginning and almost forgot about that.
I may have only been just two notes going back and forth.
So though already we've got our four,
um,
and,
and maybe that's all we need.
Let's listen to just the big,
it's not a sh a long extra,
let's listen to the beginning of this again.
[inaudible] [inaudible] right.
They're very distant.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
brass is as [inaudible]
water
music has a kind of intensity to it,
you know,
stop.
I give up,
I surrender.
It's got that element to it.
There's an intensity to it here.
So,
uh,
that,
that could be even the fifth component in our,
our thinking.
So all of this leads us to the conclusion that this is a piece of 20th century
music by the woman composer Ellen's village.
And you have Ellen's village of course,
as the basis of your listening exercise,
45 of that you've done,
this is simply another piece called celebration.
It's a pretty so far pretty celebration by Ellen's village written in 1984.
So it's a fairly recent piece of music in the modernist style.
Not postmodernists but modernist.
Um,
okay,
well I'm going to,
I think a variety is always useful in life.
I'm willing to,
and I asked Linda yesterday,
Linda,
you prepare a piece and,
and but don't tell me what it is cause I want to go through the same thought
processes that other people have.
So Linda has prepared a piece and I don't know whether she's going to use the
piano or whether she's going to use the audio player.
You want me to play it for you?
You're okay.
Okay.
Okay,
nice.
What are you hearing?
Who has any thoughts?
Regular meter.
All right.
Uh,
that's,
that's a very good,
important point for this particular period.
What else?
What kind of instruments?
Oh
yeah.
Strings in the foreground.
So this means we have probably an orchestra.
Uh,
what,
well,
okay,
before we get there.
Okay.
It's spring is in the foreground of this particular ensemble.
Could anybody tell what the solo instrument was?
All right.
Uh,
so we've had regular meters.
String is in the foreground,
a solo instrument.
MMM.
What might you say about the relationship between the Solo Instrument and the
bigger ensemble?
Cool.
I guess that's maybe a pretty obvious,
but
that's true.
They seem to be at about a similar level.
Uh,
it doesn't seem like the ensemble is very big and we have them playing one after
the other,
which is a characteristic of something that we learned about.
Um,
rhythmically this goes with the meter.
Was it regular or irregular?
Pretty regular.
Um,
you could tap your foot to it.
Uh,
you could hear a melody.
I'll just play a couple more
second.
Okay.
So the solo instrument is playing something kind of simple or something kind of
virtuosic and impressive.
She'd be impressive that you hear lots of little trills.
It's leaping all over the place.
It's showing off.
Uh,
and this is a feature of something we learned about.
So who would like to,
uh,
guess what period wherein
Michael Close.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess I can see why you might,
uh,
why,
why don't you say romantic
fairly quickly,
but they were saying,
which makes you realize that you can't always tell by the size of the orchestra.
Uh,
sometimes it's better to listen for some of the more abstract features such as
what the orchestra is doing,
the harmonies.
How about the harmonic language?
Was it pretty,
um,
surprising or a little more expected?
I mean,
this is maybe something that's going to help you zero in a little bit more.
Yeah.
Pretty expected.
Not Very,
uh,
not very surprising harmonies for anybody else.
Have another
or do you want to correct yourself though,
yet
a little bow?
Tie it out of sequence.
[inaudible] phrase.
What does that suggest to you?
I cadence very good.
Which I is very strong.
And what period classical.
Yeah.
I mean these things do happen and other periods,
but this is sort of a quintessential classical,
very particular genre.
Does anybody know what genre we're in?
Yeah.
Concerto exactly.
So this was the Mozart bassoon concerto.
Who knew that Mozart wrote a bassoon concertos is one of the bassoon is the
biggest pieces in their repertoire.
And we thought the bassoon was sort of amusing instruments.
That's why there are lots of leaps and it sounds a bit like a clown anyway,
so that,
uh,
that's a concerto example for you,
which is not a piano.
Oh yeah.
That is a great question.
I wonder if I ought to defer to professor.
Right.
Well,
um,
let's,
let's work through this together.
One way we've been all over this and that is the size of the orchestra.
And we talk when we had the lecture on 19th century orchestral music,
how all of these instruments come in.
So the,
the orchestra has many more and many more varied instruments in it ranging from
top Piccolo down to middle English horn,
down to bottom,
contra based,
bassoon tube,
it and things like that.
So it was the orchestra,
particularly low brasses and that kind of sound that typifies the sound
generally for orchestral music in the 19th century.
Then the,
uh,
whereas Daniel was talking about bow tie,
they're tied together.
Uh,
you don't do what what he was in the meeting there perhaps was that we have this
kind of of paired phrasing or neat,
neat little units of phrasing that can be tied together.
That's a component of classical music.
As you go into the romantic period,
the themes,
the melodies become much more expansive.
And,
uh,
someone I think said early on,
he has pretty,
maybe the first point was it's pretty regular meter in this particular piece of,
of,
of classical music by Mozart too.
Mozart,
bassoon can share it.
Okay.
One 93 jet.
Right?
Um,
so the,
uh,
the regularity of the themes and the balance and symmetry is part and partial of
the classical period.
You move into the romantic,
you have expansive themes,
but by way of Contra distinction there,
then the rhythm becomes not necessarily more flaccid but more loose.
And we talked about this,
a phenomena of Rubato for example.
So flexible rhythms,
flexible tempos,
less clear meters in the romantic period.
Um,
and not to overdo it,
but it may be this idea of just beautiful melody and it,
it is of course in this 19th century that we hold,
get the whole idea of the Bel Canto sound.
If anybody read,
uh,
rothsteins uh,
no.
Andrew Thomas Seeney's article that I pointed you to about Bel Canto.
He said,
actually the beginning of that starts back with the composers of piano music of
that same period.
And then the opera composers begin to go into it.
So who wrote this?
Yeah.
Lovely it.
And a beautiful,
well,
the whole idea of beautiful melody.
Yeah.
Multirotor.
Lot of beautiful melodies too.
So did Bob.
But somehow beautiful melody,
just warm,
rich.
Melody is very important in romantic music.
So this is a good example.
Rich
harmonies,
a broader palate.
Uh,
and um,
then the classical period.
I could play one other piece here just to differentiate romantic piano music
from this sound.
Uh,
oh.
Uh
hmm.
So that's a piece by Mozart.
You could say that the melody is just as beautiful.
That's gorgeous melody too.
That's lovely.
You could use that as his film music just as well as you could.
The other page.
So the first piece that I played
Yup.
Is by any takers on that whole piano music of the 19th century.
Uh,
anybody,
if you've peaked through the textbook,
that is good.
Yeah.
Chopin and Frederic Chopin.
So that's a classic,
a classic,
quintessential moment of Chopin,
quintessential moment of,
of Chopin,
which become a classic indeed.
It became a kind of,
uh,
Judy garland and used to seeing this.
I,
I'm forever chasing rainbows.
It got turned into a,
a pop song,
uh,
in,
in the 20th century because it's such a,
a drop dead beautiful melody.
But the difference here is the,
in the pianos,
the terms of expansion.
Here's the Chopin's sound,
here's
and the cord sometime ago,
interesting
Christine harmonic shifts,
but the Mozart by comparison is very plain harmonic
please.
And very limited in terms of the range and limited somewhat in terms of the
texture,
but kind of base is this,
you're talking about how we identify style.
All you'd really have to do is listen to about one second of this.
Oh,
I know what that is.
That has to be what?
Uh,
um,
Emily,
that's an Albertie base and LBD basis used only in what period of music history.
Classical.
Okay,
so that's it.
You hear that it's got to be in a 40 year period,
roughly 17,
72,
18,
10 or so.
And then they,
then they stopped using it.
How do we know that this is specifically Mozart?
This is above and beyond the Pale that if you put down Beethoven for this,
it'd be great if you put down heightened for this,
it'd be great.
Schubert for this would be great.
Mozart for this.
It would be great.
How do we know it's Mozart?
There's one little moment here
that when he takes that line and nobody else made it fun,
he loves to do that.
What did he do there?
He inserted what?
What kind of scale is that?
Yeah.
Emily says chromatic.
So he inserted just a little bit of of chromaticism there and that's a finger
fingerprint of Mozart.
So we're parsing this out a little bit more fine than we need to do,
but that's the kind of the next step on this.
Okay.
Uh,
where are we?
Let's do one more piece.
Let's put,
uh,
yeah,
let's put this one in and go to track 18.
I believe.
Anybody want to ask a question while we're queuing this up?
Oscar,
Beethoven wouldn't really use so much of an Ostinato as he would just sit there.
I see your point on one chord and kind of hammer you over the head with that.
Um,
but I say that's a prayer.
That's an Ios.
It's a good point.
It's more sophisticated in a way that we need get into in here.
Uh,
but I wouldn't say Beethoven uses Ostinato so much as iteration and admittedly
it's a fine line between Ostinato in iteration,
but,
but kind of sitting on something and just kind of repeating that,
maybe that chord over and over and over again in a way that Mozart and Schubert
being fundamentally constructors of melody wouldn't necessarily do
everything.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
You could,
you could look upon the famous day Ttt,
him,
Papa,
Papa as an Ostinato.
People don't normally do that,
but that's,
that's just fine and dandy.
It may be something particular to Beethoven rather than the,
you're a general,
but a yes,
you're,
you're right about that.
So good for you,
Oscar.
One Craig.
Nothing at this point.
Uh,
any other question?
All right,
let's go on.
We'll hear one last piece and I'll let you go.
Although it's a fairly long one.
18 sorry.
Yeah.
Long Way to go
is that plane.
Oh
Huh.
Oh phooey.
Oh,
there's nothing.
We had the CD.
I just played it in my office a few minutes ago.
Say it out loud.
This one is the city.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
let me,
let me check the,
the track number here.
Yup.
Sorry for the delay.
Any other questions?
Is We vet?
Maybe I'll just dance up here.
Angela,
go ahead.
Well,
you could use him as a swing player.
In other words,
if you hear a piece that you think is Beethoven,
you put that down as classical.
That's fine.
You put that down as romantic.
That's fine too.
So we're,
we're sort of said,
uh,
all right,
let's just go ahead and listen to this and then we can go.
Okay.
Stop it.
Your time is short.
Go Up to about one 35 on that a CD.
Something else is going to happen.
Okay.
Stiff.
Stop here.
Now there should be one thing there that's a dead giveaway in terms of period.
And what would that be,
Zack?
The harpsichord.
Okay.
Because we've said before that really the Harpsichord doesn't get much in the
way of legs,
in the history of music until the Baroque period,
and then it disappears as it's replaced by the piano.
Uh,
for the most part,
um,
in the classical period.
So Baroque period is all all uh,
oh,
it can be readily identified here.
Shouldn't be by,
by the presence of the Harpsichord,
a w.
But what else did we hear in these very short excerpts?
Well,
let's go back to the beginning then and listen to the rhythm
[inaudible] coming into court or something.
[inaudible]
regular rhythm here and in this rhythm and this,
this particular sale goes on and goes unchanged for about a minute and 35
seconds or so.
Uh,
and that's another aspect of this,
not only regular rhythm but a regular ethos in the music of the Baroque period.
Now let's listen to this last component here and uh,
then we'll stop with this.
Let's go back to one 35.
One more time
please.
So what are we hearing here and why is this further evidence of music coming
from the Baroque period?
Mary Pat.
It's a few.
Okay.
And we studied the few of them.
We said the few came into being in the Baroque period,
principally under the aegis of Js Bach.
So there we've got our four bullet points or four pieces of supporting evidence
for the conclusion that we came to rather early on.
Is that pointed out,
uh,
by the presence of the Harpsichord.
There any final questions before we stop?
If not,
I have a request.
You may have heard that.
Unfortunately our good friend Richard Lawley,
uh,
has had a serious medical issue that he is dealing with.
Um,
and he was,
he was always such a wonderful guy and this was going to be the highlight of his
career.
He was going to take over the mastership of Jonathan Edwards College.
Um,
and unfortunately this happened.
So I'd be very grateful to you and we've got a couple of get well cards out
there and Richard is always very much interested in our Yale students.
Uh,
and it'd be great if on the way out,
you would be good enough to sign your name there,
uh,
on those cards and we'll be sure that they get over to Richard.
Okay.
Thanks very much.
And I'll see you
next Wednesday,
six days from now.